la decisión de Estados Unidos iniciaron
una nueva investigación sobre el
asesinato de chirina buacle ha sacudido
laferres relaciones que mantiene con
Israel Aunque ni el departamento de
Justicia ni el FBI han brindado
confirmaciones ni detalles sobre ella el
gobierno interino de Israel ya salió al
cruce de la pesquisa que fue informada
por primera vez por el medio
estadounidense político el ministro de
defensa benigans en la calificó de grave
error y anticipó que Israel no cooperará
a la vez que defendió los resultados de
la investigación interna de las fuerzas
israelíes esta en septiembre había
determinado que era probable que por
error un soldado israelí haya asesinado
durante la redada de las fuerzas
israelíes en jenning en ciscordania
ocupada el 11 de mayo pasado pero Israel
no ha determinado responsabilidades y se
ha negado a abrir una investigación
criminal la decisión también significa
un giro en la en la política de Estados
Unidos que hasta aquí se había
conformado con las explicaciones
israelíes Y ese también un movimiento
muy poco habitual porque se trata la
investigación que involucra a uno de sus
aliados más fuertes y que pone en
cuestión el discurso habitual de Israel
que defiende el accionar de sus soldados
en los territorios ocupados la familia
decirina bucle que durante meses ha
abogado por un mayor involucramiento del
gobierno de joeyden a calificado la
investigación como un paso importante y
pidió que Estados Unidos utilice todas
las herramientas a su alcance para
encontrar respuestas y determinar
responsabilidades cabe recordar que
investigaciones independientes de medios
y declaraciones de Testigos presenciales
han rechazado las alegaciones israelíes
de que en el momento de la muerte de
aboacle había fuego palestino y además
la periodista asesinada se encontraba
correctamente identificada con un
chaleco y un casco con la leyenda de
prensa